have you ever imagined what twilight
would look like without the iconic trio
of robert pattinson kristen stewart and
taylor lautner
the truth is the film franchise was just
one casting decision away from changing
the twilight we now know and love
our pets in case do were pretty unknown
when they took on the role of edward and
bella
but during auditions they went up
against some pretty notable names
lily collins henry cavill and jennifer
lawrence were all looking for a piece of
that twilight pie
in this video we are taking a look at
all the major celebs who you'll be
shocked to find out auditioned for the
vampire phenomenon
what
the first celeb is coming to you all the
way from pacific coast academy
or as we call it the boarding school
everyone dreamed about as a teen
any guesses if you said jamie lynn
spears you're correct
jaime tucked away her southern accent to
audition for the one and only bella swan
but she had to be forced by her managers
she even admitted to calling the role
stupid in an interview with nylon
little did she know what was actually in
store for the cast of twilight but the
world had other plans for the actress
anyway
jaime revealed that she later realized
the reason she wasn't feeling too great
during the actual audition
she was pregnant tom felton may have
been our childhood crush but you all
have to admit that his charming good
looks carried all the way into adulthood
and those charming good looks were
almost featured in the twilight
film's new moon and eclipse he was up
for two separate characters
first producers thought he would fit
perfectly as the volturis alec
but he was just a little too old for the
role they reconsidered him again for the
part of riley in eclipse but ultimately
he just didn't get the part anyone else
now kind of curious how draco malfoy
would look as a vampire
one thing is for sure we'd have no
problem spending eternity by his side
before lily collins made it big one of
her first auditions was for bella
jamie lynn spears actually said the two
auditioned on the exact same day
she of course didn't land the role but
it didn't phase her she's a firm
believer
that everything happens for a reason and
everyone gets the roles they were meant
to
well we could definitely see lilly
collins taking on bella
if she got the role we might never have
gotten some of her other films
like the blind side and mirror mirror
that's right guys jayla was this close
to being a part of another major y.a
universe
before she auditioned for the role of
bella she was a huge fan of the entire
series
so finding out that kristen who wasn't a
fan got the part instead
didn't quite sit right with her in the
beginning but in the end said
we're all auditioning for all sorts of
things you just get like five pages and
they're like
act monkey there were actually rumors
circulating that the reason jennifer
didn't land the role was because she was
too
tough to play the character guess you
can say she's more of a mockingjay than
a swan
let's face it half of the twilight
audience rushed to the theaters on
premiere days
just to see robert pattinson in action
but there was another person stephanie
mayer had in mind for edward before the
official casting superman
henry cavill was her perfect vision of
edward before they realized he was a
little too old
but despite never auditioning henry took
the whole ordeal as a huge compliment
saying
if a writer were to say that i'm the
writer's ideal choice that's enormously
flattering michelle was a pro at
vampires even before twilight she had
already starred in buffy the vampire
slayer for years
she never actually got the chance to
audition but was instead friends with
director catherine hardwick
and was in talks but things just never
went in that direction
she didn't seem to be bummed out though
i guess schedules never worked out
i already have buffy i've already done
the vampire thing
guess you could say vanessa hudgins was
looking for the start of something new
when she auditioned for twilight she had
her sights set on werewolf leah
clearwater
she was interested in the role after
reading the novels herself while we
never really got any confirmation that
she auditioned
a screenwriter from the film spoke about
how they heard vanessa hudgins was going
up for the part of leah
we're not going to lie seeing vanessa as
part of jacob black's pack could
definitely be considered a missed
opportunity
just saying before she could get herself
sucked into the world of pretty little
liars
lucy hale was looking to land a spot in
both the cullen clan
and the notorious volturi she auditioned
for the role of alice in the first film
after reading the book she might have
been unsuccessful but still came back
during the casting of the twilight saga
new moon and auditioned for jane they of
course went with dakota fanning for the
role but lucy hale didn't take it too
hard
i love everyone they've cast i'm such a
believer in everything that's happening
for a reason
and it's all about timing i like where
i'm at right now
franco took a shot at another major
movie after his role in superbad
but his audition for edward didn't get
extremely far i tested for edward cullen
i don't know how close i was
i read for katherine hardwick but who
knows he told mtv
but a few years later another franco
stepped up to the plate
james he actually reached out to the
production team for breaking dawn
seeing if he could land a role at the
time he was part of a twilight stage
piece written by a yale student
and thought it would be cool to actually
get a part in the film but unfortunately
the director bob condon just couldn't
find a role that made sense
channing's situation is a tad bit
different he didn't exactly audition for
twilight but was being considered for
the role of riley in the twilight saga
eclipse after one of the screenwriters
suggested he'd fit the role perfectly
but that's as far as his role in
twilight ever got we're just putting it
out there
adding channing to the lineup of actors
the franchise already had
would have been one heck of a show are
you ready for this one the things fans
taylor lautner was almost replaced in
new moon could you imagine if that
actually happened
the creators knew they needed to embody
jacob's transformation in new moon
and thought the easiest way was to
replace him with someone like michael
coppon
michael told j14 that he had nothing
against taylor personally
but that it's a matter of going with the
storyline it goes with the territory
luckily taylor took up the challenge and
transformed perfectly for jacob
for millennials and older gen z's
watching halloweentown was a disney
tradition
every october and we're not afraid to
say that when sarah paxton
replaced marnie's original actress it's
stung well
it looks like she was also rivaling for
another major role in our lives
bella swan there have been no reports
about how far she got in the audition
process
but we do know she was at least
considered for the job
this next casting would not only have
made twilight look a bit different but
the hit comedy show shits creek as well
dustin milligan was up for the role of
edward in the first film but ultimately
wasn't chosen from the bunch
i did my best edward cullen he told
access hollywood but then brought a
little humor into the situation
saying he was rejected because he didn't
have a british accent
if he did make it to the level of fame
twilight brought its actors we may have
never seen him in shit's creek
everything happens for a reason right
you might be thinking
wait i thought jaime campbell bower was
in twilight and you're right he was
he played volturi member caius but he
originally auditioned for edward in the
first film
we again don't know exactly how far he
got in the process
but at least he got to be a part of the
franchise in some capacity
it was probably the english accent i'm
really good at it
tyler posey was neck and neck with
taylor lautner when it came to
auditioning for jacob black
the two apparently saw one another at
every audition i saw taylor lautner at
all of these auditions and i knew he was
auditioning for twilight also
the sad part is they never even let
tyler posey know if he got the roll or
not
he found out after seeing taylor at
another audition where he told tyler he
was filming twilight ironically
tyler went on to land another role as
the werewolf in the hit series
teen wolf well we love the way twilight
came to life back in 2008 we have to
admit it would be pretty interesting to
see how different things would be with
an entirely different cast
would it be darker more humorous maybe
it wouldn't have grown to the level of
fame that it did
do you think that they made the right
decisions when it came to casting
let us know in the comment section below
don't forget to hit that subscribe
button and give this video a like if you
want more content from the things
talk to you later